Today's case felled versus Henry s
Levian sons concerns breadcrumbs,
not the kind that fall off slice
of slices of bread as you eat it,
but rather industrial made machine
ground breadcrumbs Felds company,
the crushed toast company entered into
a contract with Levine and son's bakery
to buy all of the breadcrumbs they would
produce in the upcoming year with the
contract set to renew every year unless
one party gave the other six months
notice over the course of the year and
sons produced and sold more than 250 tons
of breadcrumbs,
but over that time they decided that 6
cents per pound they had agreed to and
the contract was too low.
They tried to get fell to agree to a
price of price increase of 7 cents per
pound,
but when he refused,
they shut down their breadcrumb making
operation and dismantled all of the
machinery involved,
the stale loaves of bread that
they would have used making crumbs.
They instead sold for animal feed.
Once they did this,
they stopped selling any crumbs to the
crush toast company as their output was
now zero filled then sued.
Considering this to be a
breach of their contract.
We're looking at the decision from the
New York Court of Appeals on appeal from
denial of both parties motion for
summary Judgment and so the underlying
procedural question is whether there is
a question of material fact for a jury
to decide in this case.
In order to answer this question,
Judge Cook looks at the substantive
legal question of whether the seller was
required to produce breadcrumbs or if
Levian sons could satisfy its obligation
by handing over the zero
breadcrumbs it produced.
Judge Cook relies on the
uniform commercial codes,
rules for output and
requirements contracts.
We've encountered these sort of
contracts before, for example,
in the sooner sand case,
but it's worth a quick refresher in an
output contract as we have in this case,
the buyer agrees to purchase all of a
given product that the seller makes in a
requirements contracts.
On the other hand,
the seller agrees to make as much of a
given product as the buyer requires or
needs. Note that in each of
these types of contracts,
one party has discretion over the quantity
of goods sold in output contracts.
It's the seller while in requirement
contracts, it's the buyer.
What we have in this case
is an output contract.
Since Levian son is obliged to sell
its entire output to the crushed toast
company, the agreement is only
exclusive in one direction.
Though the crush toasts company is
allowed to buy crumbs from others.
The key provision of the UCC is section
two three Oh six subsection one and
Forbes us at the party with discretion
does not have unlimited discretion.
They must determine the quantity in good
faith in accordance with their actual
output or requirements and that quantity
cannot be unreasonably disproportionate
to what the party's estimated or expected.
Courts have generally prioritize the good
faith requirement over the prohibition
of unreasonably disproportionate
amounts output in requirement contracts.
Give us another context to learn what
the law demands in terms of good faith,
you should see these
discretionary quantity cases
that they generally fit into
the categories that judges suitor and
Posner called discretionary performance as
opposed to good faith in
formation or in termination.
But this particular case is more of a
good faith in termination since Levian
sons by choosing deceased production
is also an essence terminating the
contract.
Judge Cook looks at what the UCC
provision means for the case at hand.
He finds that under New York law,
good faith cessation of production
terminates any further obligations and
excuses further performance,
so the simple fact that Levy and sons
cease producing breadcrumbs is not
sufficient for felled to win the case.
The question is whether the
seller acted in good faith.
Levian sons says that producing
breadcrumbs was economically not feasible,
but that's too vague and permissive.
A test for Judge Cook.
We need to look at the motives,
cook fines,
that it's not enough for a seller to
simply find that it is making less profit
than expected.
Rather continued production must
actually imperil the businesses continued
operation or or push it into bankruptcy.
Otherwise they are bound by the price
they agreed to when they formed the
contract even with judge cooks.
Clarification,
this rule is not obvious. It's not clear
why bankruptcy should be sufficient.
Leveraged Buyouts may leave businesses
with very little room for reduced
profitability,
but that shouldn't affect their
obligations to contractual partners.
One possible economically sensible
rule would be due excuse performance.
When the joint profits of the seller
and buyer combined are negative,
that's one of the parties losses
exceed the other party's gains from the
transaction. This case, however,
looks pretty clearly like bad faith that
at least on the facts that we have here,
the bakery only dismantled its machinery
after its attempts to extort a higher
price from the buyer were unsuccessful.
The court remands so that the ultimate
decision on this factual question will be
made by the jury.
This decision is one of several areas
where courts have conditioned to
corporations legal duties on whether
fulfilling the duty would drive the firm
into bankruptcy.
For example,
if a set of disabled employees
request reasonable accommodation,
an employer is less likely to need to
grant the request if doing so would drive
the employer and the bankruptcy.
But in today's world of modern finance,
the risk of bankruptcy can be somewhat
under the firm's own control and in part
a function of how the choose the
firm chooses to finance itself.
Highly leveraged firms that are financed
more with debt than equity will be more
susceptible to bankruptcy, but
bankruptcy, and in that case,
in the case of a highly leveraged firm,
doesn't mean the firm
isn't viable economically.
It just means that the firm will have
to reorganize and the erstwhile bond
holders will become the new shareholders
of the post bankrupt from imagine two
identical firms that produce widgets.
Both are wholly financed by equity or
stock and both are worth $100 million.
They'd have to lose a lot of money
before they hit the bankruptcy point.
But now imagine that one firm decides to
do a leverage buyout where it borrows a
bunch of money by issuing bonds and uses
this money to buy back almost all of
its shares.
The firm is still worth 100 million,
but now it's possible that 99 million
of it will be owned by the bond holders
and just 1 million by the remaining
shareholders after the leveraged buyout.
The second firm is much closer
to the point of bankruptcy,
but should the law allow the second
firm to have lower duties with regard to
output contracts and duties
of reasonable accommodation,
the economist would say no
and instead argue that viable,
the viability of the bread production
should turn more on the joint
profitability of production
for the buyers and the sellers.
Let's take a quick look at subsection
two of section two three Oh six as well.
This provision says that when the buyer
and seller have a contract with an
exclusive dealing provision,
they must unless otherwise agreed,
use best efforts.
The duty of making best efforts is usually
seen as a default duty to the other
side, uh, of a contract when the, uh,
when there is exclusive dealing
lady death. Gordon, for example,
promise to deal exclusively
with wood and wood in exchange,
implicitly promised to use best efforts
to promote her endorsements here.
Levy and sons agreed to
sell exclusively to Feld,
but we don't need Felds
promise of best efforts. Uh,
so we might think that filled would
promote the sale of breadcrumbs because
felled had already committed
to buy all of levies,
output and the parties and making an
output contract are not expecting the
seller to make best
efforts to supply the good,
just an effort to supply an
amount that is in good faith.
Okay,
so let's try a quiz.
Imagine that we had the same
contract as in this case,
but as the year comes to an end and
Levian son realizes that this contract is
extremely profitable the following year,
instead of 250 tons,
they produce 5,000 tons of breadcrumbs.
This felled of a suit for breach
of contract. Well, probably yes,
felled would advocates in this scenario,
Levy and sons produces 20 times the
amount of breadcrumbs he would have
expected, uh, based on the first year.
And the jury would likely conclude
that this amount is unreasonably
disproportionate under subsection one
of two three Oh six so let's recap.
We have seen that when parties enter
and output or requirements contract,
the party that has discretion over the
quantity of goods sold must act in good
faith and not impose a
quantity unreasonably
disproportionate to what the other
party would expect either based on an
explicit estimate or based on past or
normal behavior.